lenny frickin kravitz
the king the young legend himself
you are um quite incredible sir actually
first of all
this whole vibe that you're giving me
right now is very lenny
it's very i'm i'm i'm in the studio
this this is where i live most of the
time yeah you're a cool cat
all right let's first start off with you
partnered with stella artois for their
heartbeats campaign
which is designed to help encourage
canadians to pause and consider
investing their heartbeats and the
people who matter most so
at what point in your life did you have
that moment where
you realized you had to prioritize time
for your loved ones
you know it's it's it's a continuous
journey yeah and and a discipline
but i was very fortunate to grow up in a
family
where love was the priority
and i think a lot of us that maybe
weren't
awakened to that uh
you know are seeing that during these
during any times but especially during
these times where we're forced to
go inward to really
learn to uh communicate
and be present for each other
um it's a it's a great message to
reinforce
you know how do you want to live your
life
how do you want to spend your energy
your heartbeats yeah you know
well i want to invest in love and i want
to invest in people
and i want to share i want to be of
service and
uh you know it's a beautiful thing and
and during this year
um where i've been in this lockdown
you know position here in the bahamas
yeah um
it's been a great time to reset to
reflect
and you just realize that you know
it's about love and it's about people
things
possessions money yes you need certain
things and you have to pay your bills
and you have to
you know live within this system yeah
but the most
important thing uh is sharing love
with other human beings yeah i love that
um
this campaign was inspired by the
ongoing global health crisis
so many of us have found ourselves at
home so have you taken on any new
hobbies or
just rediscovered any old passions
hobby music same old hobby
it doesn't change you know um you know i
i
i do my music you know i do photography
um
i've been in the garden you know my
garden is done has done well
this year i've been here almost a year
now on march 4th
it will be a year and uh since i left
paris and i was in the middle of
my u.s tour um
so you know i've spent a lot of time in
nature
and a lot of time uh with a very small
group of people
very small yeah so it's been
a really nice you know reintroduction
to a very simple life yeah but that
is rich yes
it's important um your music has brought
joy
for so many people and you've been doing
it for over three decades which is
insane
um but what do you feel is your secret
to success
the only thing i can say because i don't
know why or what other than
you know god has blessed me and and and
i'm dedicated
to what i do i love what i do yeah i'm
still hungry i'm still inspired
um but i would say if there was any
piece of advice you know for any person
it's just
be yourself find out who you are
you know and be authentic because
that is what is is beautiful it's when
you're authentic when you
argue when you accept yourself and that
in itself is a journey that's a
continuous uh
um you know discipline as well
yeah do you ever listen to your own
music
like driving gardening maybe
cooking are you ever just jamming to
yourself no no
very rarely i when i listen to my music
when i'm making an album so right now
i'm making two albums
and i hear it almost every day because
it's like homework i'm working on it
i'm shaping it i'm sculpting it um but
when it's done
that's it other than
rehearsal because i have to teach
musicians
and we have to listen to it but that's
it i don't i don't
put it on for uh for my own enjoyment i
listen to other people
just checking um when you're working on
new material like who
is your litmus test whose opinion do you
trust most with your music
my own feeling i mean i make the music
for myself yeah i'm i'm grateful
uh when people enjoy it yeah and it
becomes
part of their lives but i truly make the
music for myself it's something that
i don't even choose it i i accept the
music that i'm given
except the music that i hear
and sometimes it may not be what i was
looking for i may have had an
idea of what i wanted and it comes out
opposite yeah but i've learned to accept
it because you know
um it's an offering
i like that um what do you want to say
with your music now
at this state of your life and really
the state of the world
the same thing i started out doing 31
years ago
yeah uh let love rule i mean that is
the nucleus of everything that i do
february is black history month and you
have been a positive figure in the black
community for so many years but
you know as a successful businessman a
musician a father
um what advice would you pass along to
other young people of color
just looking to follow in your footsteps
that you know maybe they feel
discouraged i feel like you've already
given a lot of great advice but
again particularly for them again be
yourself and be proud of who you are
yeah be proud of your
background yeah and uh your heritage
your family your ancestors
you know embrace that uh
we've had a a uh i'll call it a
beautiful struggle
you know and we're moving forward every
day as human beings and
uh and uh there's so much to do
and each person has so much to offer
that's one thing i think a lot of people
don't
embrace how much they really have to
offer
if they tap into their true gift lastly
i feel like you're good at
everything i really just feel like
you're good at everything and even
fashion
not not not not really it's funny i was
what are you not good at
not not to drop names at all because but
i was on the phone yesterday with chris
bosh
basketball player yeah and uh he plays
guitar and we were talking about
he wants to get together and and and
play
and he was asking me for some uh
things he could practice and i was
letting him know that uh i have no
basketball talent
whatsoever i i i didn't get any of that
so uh none no i'm not good at everything
no
can you like dribble i mean
yeah basically okay and you can get it
in the middle basically
but i but i don't have that ball thing
you know what i mean
uh i played baseball as a kid but
basketball
not so great wow we've uncovered the one
thing that you're not good at and i have
a feeling
i'm sure there's more but that's
something i was talking about just
yesterday
i love that well i appreciate your time
lenny you are
so incredibly talented but also very
inspiring
um so i really appreciate your time and
i hope you stay safe over in bahamas
thank you so much thank you so much